this is jocko podcast number 259 with me
jocko willink the a1es arrived just as
the team started taking incoming mortar
fire
godwin quickly calculated the
coordinates for the mortar's location
and
and the information was passed on to
covey who in turn related to the a1es
a laconic whistling voice came back down
the line
it's crispy critter time so y'all keep
your heads down
within seconds the area in front of the
team exploded into flame
the deadly napalm coating everything in
its erupting path flaming nva soldiers
ran
briefly toward the team before falling
to the ground and agonizing death throws
the hand grenades and ammunition they
carried cooking off like firecrackers
unfortunately the elephant grass was
also set on fire the napalm had
definitely slowed the nva advance
but it had not stopped it covey reported
that extraction shot extraction choppers
were five minutes out
and the team needed to move fast
two gunships from the seventh air cav
roared
over the lz watkins put out two
bright orange marker panels and the gun
ships confirmed they had the team in
sight
as they loop back to make their first
strafing run the gun ships reported that
a large enemy force was moving toward
the lz
and they were going to attempt to
discourage it
as they made their run pouring m60
machine gun fire
and rockets into the enemy rt lion could
see the air filled with green tracers
hitting the helicopters
they were taking a vicious beating but
they hung in there and kept pouring fire
down on the nva
it was an incredible show of raw guts
and determination
covey came on the radio to say the
gunships had taken casualties and were
leaking fuel
oil hydraulic fluid and just about
everything else so they were being
forced to head home
but the extraction slicks were on
station
rt lion looked around and could see its
salvation coming toward it
on its nose although they were
flying at a good clip it appeared as if
they were moving at an
agonizingly slow speed as with the
gunships before them they were taking a
horrendous amount of fire
one chopper was hit badly and began
losing fuel
after a brief confab the rescue package
suddenly broke off its approach
and headed back the way it had come
leaving nothing but smoke and
r t lions hopes for rescue behind
when watkins asked covey what this meant
in terms of time on the ground
all hartness could do was say that he'd
contact the s3 and ask for a new
set of extraction assets asap in the
meantime he promised to get more
tactical air support over the team
and do all he could to keep them alive
while watkins appreciated the sentiments
this did not do much to raise his
spirits
in his heart of hearts he felt the
team's position was precarious
and likely to get much worse and quickly
the nva had literally thousands of men
it could throw at the team
while the team had only so much
ammunition and not much by way of cover
what he told his team members however
was that there was going to be a slight
delay
and reminded them to keep vigilant and
be ready for an attack
what he didn't have the heart to tell
them was it could be hours before
another rescue attempt was made
their stay at oscar 8 was far from over
one of the brews suddenly signaled that
nva troops were crawling toward the team
through the elephant grass
the news was passed on to covey who
responded that he had two a1 e's
standing by
one loaded with cbus and the other with
rockets both aircraft had their
deadly 20 millimeter cannons locked and
loaded watkins told covey to bring in
the cbu as fast as possible
and to lay it down as close to the team
as they could get
in less than two minutes the team saw an
a1e appear front
in front of their position it's 20
millimeter cannons roaring away
it flew so low they could see the pilot
turn his head to locate the team
as he released his ordinance
unfortunately some of the mini bombs
exploded so close to rt
lion that two brew received light wounds
this was distressing but watkins
consider it one of the acceptable prices
a recon team paid
to keep from being overrun by a superior
force
as the a1es departed a small group of
nva
suddenly rose up out of the grass behind
the team and charged them ak-47s blazing
on full automatic
decetta his red communist star facing
forward
rose up and opened fire at near point
blank range the brood joined in as other
groups of nva popped up from the
elephant grass and attempted assault
after assault
what followed was several hours of
deadly cat and mouse
with the mouse hunkered down in its
little hole and the nva cat making
paw swipe after paw swipe an attempt to
claw it out
or do it in an ironic situation for the
team
to find itself in while rt lion
fended off attacks covey directed
airstrike after airstrike at the nva
troops
the storage area the anti-aircraft guns
and anything else he could draw a bead
on
throughout the day primary and secondary
explosions followed one another
as the strikes found their mark whenever
the team's fate
whatever the team's fate might turn out
to be the nva were
paying a hellacious price for messing
with it
with daylight ammunition and ideas
running out
it was like a true message from god when
watkins heard covey report that south
vietnamese air force 219 special
operation
squadron had one of its legendary king
bees end route
for once watkins spirits actually rose
not that he didn't love the living
daylights out of the seventh air cav
but the vietnamese of the 219th had
time after time after time proven
themselves to be
about the most daring most imaginative
most aggressive
and all-around finest pilots on the face
of the globe
if rt lion had any chance of getting out
of this hell hole
a king b pilot was the one who would
find it and exploit it
no matter how slight the chance was or
how deadly the odds
that was simply what they were pledged
and committed to doing
day after day more good news followed
when covey relayed that the lone kingby
would be escorted by marine gunships
from hml
360 a bad bunch of flyers that went by
the code name
scarface things were definitely going to
rock and roll with them
on station scarface enjoyed nothing more
than kicking nva butt
and taking names and then coming back
around to kick more butt
just for good measure on general
principle
and for the sheer fun of it
however covey splashed a healthy dose of
cold water on watkins by reminding him
it was
very nearly dark and that despite all
the bombs dropped
rockets fired and gun runs made the
enemy was still pumping out an enormous
amount of fire
and still moving forward pulling rt
lion out of oscar 8 was going to be as
difficult and dangerous an extraction as
could be imagined
and they would have just one chance to
pull it off if they muffed it
r t lyon would be spending the night and
would most likely
not see the next morning
sobering information indeed but watkins
did not want to discourage his team
so he just gave them his best grin and
said let's get ready to go
in the distance watkins could hear the
distinctive sound
of the old nine piston sikorsky
h-34 kingby chugging its way along a
steady base note to the higher
whop of the hueys he squinted into the
twilight
and when he could finally make out their
dim silhouettes
he flashed his strobe through the barrel
of an m79 grenade launcher
so as to mask it from enemy site the
helicopters acknowledged having rt
lion's mark
and the hueys immediately divided and
made a split run
one raking the team's forward perimeter
with rockets and machine gun fire and
the other working its rear
it was a beautiful show
watkins yelled over the noise to blow
all the claymores
by setting off all the claymores at once
he hoped to avoid having
any uninvited nva join the team they
went off in a deafening blast
and blinding flash the little mouse had
roared
as the scarface duo looped around to
make their second
final run they confirmed there were
dozens of dead and dying nva
scattered around within feet of the bomb
crater unfortunately they also saw more
troops advancing
it was down to the short strokes
as the scarface gunships began their
last pass
the king bee tucked itself in behind
them and came
roaring on but rather than sat down
outside the crater and have the team
come to him as watkins fully expected
the pilot pulled up and hovered over the
crater
as the team looked up in disbelief the
old age 34
warbird began gently settling itself
down toward the team like a mother hand
about to cover her chicks
thus also discreet decreasing the
silhouette to enemy troops
by the light of the burning elephant
grass watkins was able to see into the
king bees
cockpit and was startled to find the
co-pilot seat empty
in the pilot seat was his much
admired friend captain ahn a man who had
saved watkins bacon
on many other occasions but none quite
like what he faced here
at oscar eight captain ahn lowered his
king b
toward the team with a precision and
steadiness that gave an entirely new
meaning to the word
cool his face was smooth and calm
but there was steel in his eyes as he
worked both feet and hands to maneuver
the chopper as close to rt line as he
could
at one point watkins could have sworn
that on nodded to him
as if in a casual greeting the whole
scene bordered on surrealistic
what with the lz lit by a flickering
brush fire the sounds of gunfire and
explosions
the smell of cordite and burned human
flesh and this improbable savior
hovering above as watkins had
experienced before
the action took on a dreamlike quality
sounds faded as if someone turned down
the volume the air thickened
movement appeared to be in slow motion
and the brain snapped individual frames
that would never
ever be forgotten the looks of fear or
pain on their faces
bodies being blasted backward a piece of
someone on the ground
a scrap of cloth one's own hand
clutching a weapon or shaking wildly as
it tries to execute some simple
well-rehearsed
but now impossibly difficult task this
is what war looks like
to a mind under stress watkins could
hear
small arms fire thumping into the king
bee's body as he fully expected that at
any moment
it would either pull up an exit or come
crashing down on them
but it did neither it settled into a
stationary hover
its front wheels placed delicately
inside the crater
and there it sat an unbelievable vision
a heroic portrait of an old warrior
taking a pounding but refusing to falter
watkins dasada and godwin begin heaving
the brew into the chopper
godwin followed decetta after taking an
ancient
anxious look at his team leader was next
his bright red star pointed over his
right ear
as if he wasn't quite sure whether he
wanted to be going or staying
finally in accordance with that
time-honored tradition the 1-0's feet
were the last to leave the killing
ground of oscar 8.
with the door gunner and team pouring
small arms fire and m79 rounds into the
perimeter beyond its rim
the king b lifted up
and out of the crater as a last defiant
gesture
watkins threw a red smoke grenade onto
the lz this gesture was universally
understood by everyone who supported sog
to signal that the team was safely out
the lz
clear and everyone else was free to
pound the living daylights out of it
but our t-line was not home free not yet
at least
anti-aircraft rounds were bursting
around them like a world war
ii akkack fire captain ahn was dipping
and juking in an effort to judge the
dodge that bursts and make himself
harder to track
he still looked calm cool and collected
as if he were making a routine flight
for these guys fought watkins maybe this
was
a routine flight when the king b
touched down a caisson dasada godwin
and the grinning door gunner walked
around poking their fingers into bullet
holes and counting them
but they soon gave up there were too
many and besides it was just too
unsettling
unsettling to contemplate what might
have been
watkins learned later that captain ahn
had chosen to fly
solo in the oscar 8 because he knew
exactly how dangerous this mission was
he'd lost king bees there before and was
determined not to risk more lives than
necessary
he figured if the gods ordained that his
ship go down
while trying to save rt lion it would
just be him
and the door gunner it seemed like a
simple
and perfectly logical decision no big
deal
incredibly everyone who participated in
the mission was alive and well
the men of rt lion were home seasoned
veterans
of oscar eight it had indeed
been their time after all
so that is
that is a whole different kind of
heroism
because look when you're on the ground
in many cases you don't even have a
choice
but to be a hero you either step up or
you die
but for these pilots
men like captain ahn they don't really
have to do anything heroic
they could easily say that the landing
zone's too hot or they've already been
shot or they're low on fuel
or whatever
but they're safe in their aircraft and
they see
the hell that is going on and they see
the hell that they are going into
bullets and rockets and anti-aircraft
and they go
anyway
they go anyway
men like captain nguyen ki
ahn a pilot in the south vietnamese air
force
who flew countless missions insanely
dangerous missions in support of
american
and south vietnamese sog teams
he's a recipient of the silver star and
the distinguished flying cross
and it is an absolute honor to have
captain ahn
with us here to talk about his
experiencing
fighting in vietnam laos
and cambodia captain on it's an
absolute honor to have you here thank
you
and i guess also joining us once again
is john striker meyer tilt
special forces member of sog who
has been on this podcast before couple
times a couple times
180 181 182 186 with the frenchman
247 248 and the last one with cowboy con
cowboy 258 back again
thank you so much and and when you first
came on
after the first couple times people
started asking almost
immediately to if if i could find a king
b
pilot and i know as soon as you know you
very quickly
mentioned captain ahn always
number one king b for sure thank you
so so uh on tell us about what it was
like growing up where did you grow up
uh i was grow up at hanoi
north of vietnam and uh
my father decided to move the family to
the south in 1954.
now was that after after the french got
beat yeah
so did your father kind of recognize
that bad things could happen
yes and what what did your father do for
a living
did you mean before after 55 after 54.
oh here's the uh some kind of business
to cut the lumber
like a lumberjack yeah okay and he
he he hired people to do it but he
organized the the office
and
after 54 we moved down to the south
and he worked for uh one of the uh
french company oh he worked for a french
company yeah
okay after fortune 54 and we moved to
the south okay
and what did you do how old were you
when you moved to the south
oh i was fifth uh 11 11 years old yeah
and my my my father's and myself and
my brother my younger brother at that
time he was
10 and uh to fly to the uh
with one of the friends to the south
now did you have any understanding of
what was happening
with the communists in north vietnam did
you have any understanding of that yet
oh but uh before we go to uh we uh
we went to the south then
i remember i
at night my i sleep next to my my father
and he was
a criticism i keep criticizing
what she mean because my uh
elder oldest brother was killed
in uh 45
when he was 17. okay yeah by the
communists by the communists
yeah so once you got down to south
vietnam now you're 11 years old
and what it what did you did you were
you just going to school
yes i did and since the uh
we move around all the time from hanoi
to
haifang and then go to the south
and uh
i myself and my brother next to me
we don't try to make it too great in one
year
you try to make what in one year too
great okay
were you able to do it yeah okay we did
nice
nice and uh
uh in uh city uh 62 62
yeah i joined the air force so my uh
my brother he got the scholarship from
usam
and he went here too so 1962 is when you
joined the air force yes
and and um once you joined the air force
did you know you were going to be a
pilot yes
okay but uh i didn't believe it i would
be
because i couldn't uh ride the car i
couldn't ride air
uh give me a train a course if an
airplane a bus
because every time i got in the car my
stomach was like
this guy can't come up in my mouth
truck sick train sick every single he
would get
yeah that's not fun but eventually you
were able to get over that
yes the first time my uh
ip he uh demonstrated the uh
um as in quit all the oral translation
and oh and i i i
feel my my stomachs come up and i said
oh my god how
can fry but later on i get used with it
right and i like it
i know that they have something for
american pilots and i don't know if they
made you do this they have something
where if you get
air sickness they have something i think
it's in texas it's called
spin and puke and they basically put you
in this machine
every day and it spins you around and
makes you sick until you get used to it
really yep oh yep
so i guess you didn't do that no you
didn't have to go to the spin and puke
one auto rotation helped yeah so
how long were you in the air force
before you started training to become a
pilot
when i joined in the air force in
late 62 when
and formerly it was on january 1st
of 63. okay and i was
have the basic military training
in fall and also the esl
for six months and in
in july 63
i was sent here to get attorney so you
came to america
yeah and got the uh esl again training
in
australia yeah in san antonio okay yeah
so you so you go to san antonio to
first to learn how to speak english oh
in uh
in vietnam oh okay when when i uh
get the military military training
and the esl english training
for six months and then when i went to
uh to the central new
texas of our another four months for
uh esl english language
after that i went to uh four waters
in texas okay and and what was five
waters for
for the uh primary uh helicopter
training
okay it's the uh s20 uh 23
the s23 chopper h23
chomper small another
that's like the uh that's like the
bubble canopy right
similar to that yeah different variation
yeah the old one
and and then so how long did you spend
in america training to fly
uh from uh
from the uh uh first training i uh
get the uh advanced training on the asus
23 too
and then after i finished it i went to
alabama to get the
training on the uh x-34
the king bee me and now what was your
first impression of the king bee
well it was
and
when i finish the training on the age 34
uh they i was transferred to get there i
got the training on the
highway at that time they only have
the at the school they only have the a
model
it's a weird this is a small one the a
model huey
yeah what did you like better what did
you like better the huey or the king bee
it's kidding me
because they uh they gave me help about
well at that time
thousand fifty hundred hospital okay
but the heatwave a model have only nine
hundred horsepower
but the huey is a lot smaller than the
king b yes it is smaller
and uh but did you feel like you had
more power in the king b
no no because it's too easy
too easy to fly right what's that one
because on the age 34 i got total about
10 hours how many hours 100 hours 100
hours
wow total and but on the
way i only get the 900 hours
okay and the pilot the
captain pilot who checked my uh check me
he said okay you stick you can stay home
you don't need to fly anymore
you stay home so like he can have more
time to take other people
got it other people didn't learn as
quickly as he did got it so
i was off for one weekend this week
so then so is that is that what you got
trained in you completed all that
training yeah um
and then it was going back to vietnam
yes in uh
64. about around around
july 64. so in 64
america's there but not super heavy
engaged in combat operations yet
um what was it like when you got back
were you were you starting to
anticipate were you was it starting to
seem like there was going to be a
a broader war being fought there don't
forget in june of 1964
uh roger dolan earned the first medal of
honor
at a green berea camp so there were
there were
major battles at the a camps at that
level and so
and of course the king bees even then
we're supporting some of the acans so
that was the beginning
of that war at a serious level and yes
the we didn't get the american troops
involved to hydrant valley but they
began to build up when the marines came
into da nang
so he was all part of that what year did
the marines come into da nang
there was 64 i think yeah just forced
people
yeah because it's always uh i drank in
that sort of in my mind marks the
beginning of
like heavy american combat operations
yes that's a formal battle between
american first cab right
and the nva so but yeah definitely prior
to that
it was advisors in there working by with
and through
the locals right and and yeah
um so you're seeing all that happen
you're seeing that start to unfold
were you at what point did you start
flying
the king bees in support of special
operations when i first came back from
uh from the u.s training
i i was assigned to a
217 squad and
the 2 17 squad first station at
saigon and in 60
late 65 it was a move to
canter in the south and
uh in uh
february 1966
i i i was assigned to the 83rd
group this is the
group that combined face swing and
helicopter
to fight the secret mission
and later on the
helicopter through a group become a 219
but the group of the 80 at the
helicopter group
in 83 uh space group have only four
helicopters yeah but when we
become became the 219 we have
24 of them did you know what you were
getting into
yeah with those kinds
of course he's very modest the first two
years basically from
from uh when he went to that first to
217th
the commander of that unit didn't like
north vietnamese
so he was only a co-pilot but he fly
co-pilot he get very bored he wants to
get more action
so he finally gets to be quest then he
goes and gets the action
so once you once you started uh doing
that
what was what was that like what was it
what was it like to start
going out on those operations where
there was all this
incredible intensity on the ground oh
i think he's more excited than in the
normal squadron
yeah i'd say it's probably more exciting
than a normal squadron
what was it what was the um what was the
operational
pace like how often were you getting
called to fly
what would happen would you be on
standby waiting
to go extract people would you sit and
plan with the guys from sog so you all
were working together
how did all that how did all that work
everything worked like that because they
had
he had a rotation like one week they
would be on assignment
one week they'd be training and another
week they'd be getting ready
and then in one week or so they'd be on
the side they could be up at food by
yeah then they go down the contour
wherever the most
depending on the weather what missions
were up so would would sog
ground guys go and you know would you
sit down and say okay here's what we're
going to insert
here we go up order and they would be in
for their briefing prior to launch
yeah before that we went out to the
operation that we have the briefing
what we are going to do to do and where
we are going to work
but since i was so familiar with
the whole whole board from
from here saying down to placo
mamitot the whole world around the
around
i don't need to bring map you were that
familiar with it
yeah and here's another king during
those briefings
when they're there as a 1-0 the king
bees
as we went further into the war their
briefing would say
we found uh 23 mike mike here
37 mike mike anti-aircraft weaponry in
those targets
so they would tell the covey and their
expertise would be another bonus that we
had in terms of our briefing
where not to fly and that's one of the
briefing parts so it's like we hear what
the mission was get that from s3
but we'd always hear from them then the
covey after that
oh yeah so you'd be flying
basically some kind of combat mission
every
day or two days three days at the most
or sometime
in one day yeah i threw three missions
each mission lasts about
less than two hours yeah see that's
what's cool about being a pilot
right two hours you know two hours and
you're done
if you live they come home yeah if you
have to come home you're doing all right
you're back eating good chow and
drinking a cold beer indeed
uh so so how long did it take before you
finally ended up getting shot down
ooh like when did
i know you ended up getting shot down
how long were you flying for before you
got shot down for the first time over
four years
time let's see the first time
some time in 67 or 66 i don't remember
because i was starting up one time four
times
and you shut down four times yeah and uh
i don't believe
i don't even remember which day was that
except the last time i lost my hand
remember that yeah the first time you
got shot you don't really remember what
happened the first time you got shot
down oh
uh the first time i was shut down was in
south of the maple mountain and
in the morning the we supposed to take
the
the platoon to make the security line
south of the uh mountain and marble
mountain right where fob4 was
so this is an in-country mission and
they're picking up a battalion to put it
on the south side of marble mount
because
fob4 was on the north side but and they
were having some issues they put the
battalion out there for security
purposes they're working along with the
marines
at that point and so seven o'clock in
the morning
south vietnam gets shot down
yeah yeah it's a i went now at six
o'clock and
uh this is the uh moderati uh
the two and uh when the second
king made the land and he said that he
kept uh he caught the graphite and
i told him remember which way
and i come back to my
mountain pick up more people and then
land there
again and ask him which uh
which direction is that he said two
o'clock
and i take up and have to two across his
direction and i saw a line of people
was moving with the holy
holy woman and she's a kid and
whispered you remember the two
musketeers they carry
yeah and i i totally the
crew recruiting only people civilian
people don't
don't shoot and as as long as
i finish it i heard a
long fire from that
from that life from that people from
those people
and the engine just quit
and i make i make a class do on a rice
paddy
and the uh the third shopper
of them that came down to uh pick me up
and bring me here my neck to learning
and at nine o'clock
i
and we took that shot by
the mechanics they couldn't find
any round so
they keep asking me tell or tell them
to tell them what happened what will
happen
if we couldn't find the
any uh route then it must be the
technical problem and i said yes i did
yeah i i i heard it around i already did
fire and later in the afternoon
one of the mechanics ship
he was he opened the front door
in front of the uh of the engine
and he looked around and
suddenly he he saw the uh the
the uh the lid the cap of the uh
magneto there was a hole in there
oh so that was it and uh he was
wondering
why this is there is a hole in here why
did the
the people didn't change it so he just
called the mechanic
and opened it oh my my bullet was in
there
and that much hardly ignited
wow yeah so you would go back out and
you went back out and recovered that
aircraft yeah
would you tie straps onto it and bring
it back or how would you do it
i i i go we'll go down and we had to uh
show them how to to do brick and mortar
down the aircraft bike would you bring
it back with another helicopter yeah
just tie it on and bring it back and
then start working on it
did you feel jinxed going back in that
aircraft again
or did you feel lucky you already got
shot down you let you made it
you know when uh when i i uh in the
rice paddy uh i um
i jumped out of the shop and
grabbed the uh the m3
the old one the world war ii my machine
gun
and my cruise ship bringing another
carry the uh
armor box and uh
my uh my co-pi he ran along with me
when i when i picked up the inventory i
looked back and i saw that the
the uh the water on the rice valley
was swell exactly because in the from
the
day they were shooting from the village
oh yeah still
and i ran to the border of the rice
paddy and put it again on
put the machine gunner on and load it
and i shot it i got
idiot work all these cans i shoot one
one round in a time
yeah those old those little 30 calibers
were not the most reliable
after after the first 30 years of combat
jeez
i know there's another another story
where
you got shot down again um after
and the day before kingby had been shot
down and then you went into what what
happened on that operation
uh is that uh operation the
um the day
the day before we went out and to
uh resupply and bring the wound from the
uh
from the team and
i land and pick up some and we surprised
them but
the second one was held down by the rpc
and it was about
5 00 p.m and
when i saw it and uh i came back to
go to draw and uh
no we we lost two kimberly at that time
yeah talking me on the previous day
and i decided nothing how did you feel
about going on an operation
when there was two king bees shot down
the day before
and now you have to go back in there
what did that feel like
um i think that we have
we need to bring the uh all of my friend
back
yeah and uh
when i ran to uh on uh at the
doctor uh the uh the radio man
from the camp he went out he said order
from saigon not to land anymore
and he lowered his fire
but the last decision is yours
and i said oh i'm going to go in
again and i asked kobe
and the two friendship and my
number three number four came back
i will go in again and uh
when uh yeah
i i tell them just uh
follow me and uh
when we were about five kilometers from
the lg
then you people just keep operating
and i will go down by myself and
i wait until seven o'clock at seven p.m
it's dark and uh
i say let's go and i turn around on
my line they lied even even the uh
the that's more the light you turn them
off turn them all off very
very useful very faint hard to see
and because anyway
for for a long time flying i can listen
to the
engine and how i know how much it did
it was working and
how much how how many rpm it is running
i can listen it and
when you were about five grounders from
the lc
i turn up the light and tell other
people to the
arbit wait for me and i asked the kobe
do you see me and he said that
yes so i turn up the engine
and go down would now do another to the
top of the tree recovery and ask him
again
do you still see me i said yes
okay guys and you gotta terminate
straight line left live and the audio
ahead and make a 360
with a 1990 nautical mile
make a 360 degree to uh to land on the
lg
so so the they were walking you in and
telling them
exactly where to go guiding you in yeah
at night at treetop
in the jungle this is and there's
mountains here yeah it's not like we're
flying in cambodia where it's flat
he's flying over the hills too just and
that's just part of this one another day
with a king bee pilot
at night with the lights out and he got
the everybody out
and the next day i came in again
and at uh 10 am
and when i was taking off
and i heard a
big brush and the
the chopper started to
make up because the engine was lost
they had the blaster broke up there and
blew off the engine
oh wait what blew up the engine yeah the
fire
it was it was hit by the rpg okay
right move to to keep the
the jumper to stick to the side of the
hill
and still and start a little week
load the left side down to so it can
hold onto the side of the heel
and i start with your mouth and
i say that um
the call by when i came out i could cope
with my copy he
he was on my left eye as i said run
so so let me make sure i get this you're
you're
the aircraft gets hit with an rpg yeah
the engine dies
the engine came off oh the engine came
off yeah it blew off the engine
okay and so that's why the chopper knows
how
now the chopper goes nose up yeah you're
going to crash land and you have to do
it on a hillside
yeah and so you had to kind of maneuver
the helicopter to
be at an angle yeah so it won't be
rolled out of the
hill and then so you land it basically
you are able to crash land it
and then you look at your co-pilot and
say run
and then we went uphill okay
you designed the team and then so then
you joined the saag team on the ground
yes
did you carry the amps the m30 again for
good luck yeah
no at that time we already have m60
yeah okay so you have you got the m60
off of it yeah
but uh so then what happened when you
joined up with the saag team the south
team
because of the uh oh the m16
and m18 was all over the uh
the dish and
i grabbed one of them now at first i
yeah either one of them tried to shoot
and
wherever the rpg come from but
they it didn't work because they shot
all of them
and they they they
may not both yeah
i think that the uh the girl was too dry
oh the gun was too dry yeah i couldn't
shoot anymore
okay so now you're in a perimeter i
guess yeah with your team
with the team they're wounded yeah and
this is a boon to people he had picked
up what team was this
i don't know sure sell a cartoon this is
before my time even like 67 i think so
uh
so i went around and and found
another uh m79 gun
and the grenade launcher two bikes on it
so i just
okay you shoot me now i'll be back
to you i should i should
i am the two bike i will uh m-79
and uh i start shooting from 50 meters
away from us to 200 meters
away from us how long were you guys on
the ground for before you got extracted
oh and when i uh
after after i shot the honor the grenade
i called it kobe and he said are you
still alive
yeah and i found my
rescue panel because he he was on the
sky
and he saw it he said that he saw the
the frame the line of frame go and hit
my
chopper and myself i spoke in the the
front nose i spoke
and he thought that i was not there
but when he was lucky and he said oh
you're still alive
and i say yeah but don't plan anymore
we have to move okay yeah so you hear if
that had been a ue
they're dead everybody's dead but that's
a king bee
yeah the uae and the rpg hit the engine
and blew it out which is a nine cylinder
world war ii engine from the b-17
but it's blew it out of the aircraft and
he still was able to talk about it and
walk away from it yeah
and crash land that thing like on top of
that on a sideways on a hill yeah
so so was the uh did the other aircraft
the other king b then land and pick you
guys up quickly or were you out there
for a while no we have to
we have to run uh away from the lc
with the with the team from 10 a.m to
4 p.m before i was speaking so much for
the 2-hour mission
and you're getting shot up by the nva
the whole time
yeah many times and he's learning how to
shoot the m79
in between the m16 and the m60 whatever
rounds he has
on the job training in laos
so then you come back from that mission
and then take a shower get ready
and go brief another mission that's what
you guys did no after taking on the
mission that i was sat down
i went back to uh they brought me back
to a
doctor and at that time on my
commander my squad the man and the whole
staff of the squad and came down to
uh nectar to see what happened
they couldn't believe you're still alive
and yeah and
when i first when i first seen my uh
my swan command i said that my friend
needs to have
one week to uh on the
verification to relax did he give it to
you
yeah he said okay so all you had to do
was
take a rpg hit have your engine blown
out crash land and do a six-hour gun
fight with the nva to get a week's
vacation
i don't know that seems like a rough
tour
but the the previous day one of the jobs
also got him by the rpg and
the co-pilot got killed
and the pilot
and the and the mechanic and the
decreasing
i got birthday but but uh like i bought
them home yeah and the
before the um the next day before i
left the lc i
ran back to the uh the glass landing of
the uh
the chopper that went down before yes
the previous day and try to look for
something
the if it can remain of the
co-pilot of the previous day but i
couldn't find any
the whole thing was white ass
because the aircraft was the aluminum oh
so it just burned
i used this bird
um that that wasn't your last time
getting shot down
no
what about your toe tail rote tail rotor
getting shot off
oh tail rotator cable um
it was in laos and i was taken off
and um suddenly i feel somebody
hit the body on my my foot
on my feet i mean i mean and
i asked my uh cruise ship what's
happening with the terrorist
and he he checked along and he
said he got in the tailbone
and said that the cable the control
cable on the table
with the shutdown shut off
and so because when
i feel the uh it hit the the
somebody or something something hit but
the apparel
i it is a chopper when i was taking off
this the chamber started to turn right
because we have we don't have the
control of the tail
move this cycle to the left and reduce
the power
and i accept i accept to be shot
with the other with all around
rather than glass landing so i keep
taking off with the 60 knots
and 560 knots a little bit sideway
and back from away from laos to
and i called my uh
my my they are giving me go ahead and
land first and prepare for the only
i think i extinguished
and because i i have to make a class
and i might make a long
big traffic and land make a rainy
landing when
the 10 wheeled touchdown i told him i go
back
get up the power and
he got off the power and the
but before before i tested him i told
the
uh my cruise ship tell the the team
nine of them in the shop tell the team
when i
slow down the chapter and tell them to
jump out
the nine-man team tell them do not do
them out
not to remain because we might make a
class
and and finally the the
chopper turn right and stop
when i look down like no no them jump
out
if they're still in the jumper
and did any of the nine members of the
team get wounded one guy was wounded
no nobody's wounded but yet they shot
the rotor the
the cable to the rotor yeah that's crazy
and the aircraft between the weight
and the way he adjusted the cycling
stick yeah he flew back sideways and
decreased his speed
it's like i never heard that story this
is another one of those
oh my god stories just another day
flying king beast
with captain on
now you know why we say number one pilot
i tell you one thing if at that time we
have the
uh good ship yes but to cover
ourselves then we can make a lot of
things is that right yeah
because we you know that uh when you go
after this operation
the fueling and the thinking of the
enemy
what they are now thinking we can guess
but the american you couldn't guess what
they are doing
what they are going to do so you're
saying that the american
the americans we would do random things
but the enemy
you kind of knew what they were going to
do they followed patterns
we can guess most of them wow
the americans just go out and they can
receive another grandfather somewhere
and this would suppress it
try to suppress it but for us we can
guess
where they are going to put again or
what they are going to plan
because sometimes when uh
one time i was shot i was taking off
from the aussie and
the uh i heard
heavy heavy girlfriend from up on the
right side and i look back
and i saw the nba sitting behind the uh
50 caliber and shooting at me less than
100 years
and uh so i i dive down to the bamboo
top
and make the zigzag fly but
i am i escaped but the second game they
came in and they made it
they couldn't give me uh i got shut down
shut down and
caught fire wow it's too close
less than 100 yeah
um another one uh tilt was telling me
about
was you you got something hit
and you got hit by something it almost
knocked you out of your seat
yes and there was a like a two inch hole
in the back of the king b what was that
we couldn't find any foul we couldn't
find the dda around
and i don't know what what kind of uh
what kind of uh gunnery was that but uh
at that time i was taking off from the
aussie in laos
and suddenly just like some somebody hit
me with a
hammer in the back and hit me forward
i so i i use my left hand
left left knee to hold this uh
collective
and keep trying and use my left hand
to check my back
and i said oh it's still dry
i mean i still okay no blood no bread
and when i got home the uh
i checked that one was wrong and i saw
the at the back of the backseat
the back of my seat the holes were
bigger than this one
did you guys was there any armor at all
on the king b
no no armor just aluminum aluminum
that's all can't stop anything no i said
oh yeah one there is one uh
ammo plate underneath the engine
underneath the engine they had an armor
18 inches or 18 inches wide it would
wrap up on the sides
underneath the engine that's about the
only armor i'm aware of yeah
yeah what'd you wear did you wear did
you wear a
flak vest or anything no no no point no
they have really cool king b flight
flight just a flight suit overalls
have their king being signals on them
and they have their holster
on their hip like a cowboy
they were really good looking uniforms
i like the black was best how many
operations do you think you flew
let's calculate i got four thousand
dollars
and minus one thousand now for
lysin or in the other other thing
and so three thousand three thousand
three thousand divided to
two hours for each mission
so fifteen hundred or so missions yeah
give or take
you take a hundred
these are all sod missions yeah
how often how often would you have enemy
contact on the ground when you went in
usually they
when i came in to insert the team
and i saw something
one this is like one time when i went to
the lg
and i saw the tail foot line
on the ld and the team was getting off
and said come back back back
and they come back one time and then i
saw it
and i did i brought them back right away
but most of the time when we got shot
when we take home from the aussie
when the yeah for the extraction
yeah so most of the time you could get
in
well you you would just pull the team
out almost immediately if you guys could
come right out yeah if we were
compromised and we just try to get it
back
go out if we could what percentage do
you think you guys were compromised on
the insert
probably a lot more than we realized
because they have the
lz watchers and they would like to get
us on the ground first
particularly by the end of 68 because
they had the uh
hunter killer teams that were out there
their main mission was to find us
yeah i would think they would want to
wait until you inserted right see you
insert
let the helicopters leave and then roll
you up there you go
so the insert usually good what could
would go well
unless there are days like we had that
time in november when we get shot out of
the primary
secondary and the author and the king
bees would go in
bing bing bing go have lunch they would
refuel have a little lunch
here's another target go back and do it
again and
often they would come back with bullet
holes because we literally got shot out
they
if there's enemy activity there we
wouldn't go you know you're a compromise
you want to try at least get on the
ground and get get it going with the
mission
and we had several days like that back
to back to back and the king piece got
beat up
but firstly another got shot down
and the sikorsky is just a beat that's
just a oh that's just a
horse of a aircraft yeah it only had one
door
but it had the windows so whenever we're
distracted our
the first man in the chopper would go to
the to the
left window you mean the port side port
that's what i meant
i always get the port confused with the
starboard unless i'm drinking pork
and that's what you're gonna have it's
an army man right there indeed the left
side
yes is the bulkhead secure the bulkhead
is secure there you go
you're all baby and no and then right
here we could interject
um sometimes they would be in the air
and there would be an emergency call for
any helicopter
which he did in august of 1969
i forget what you were on but this is
that mission
with scarface and scarface
was making a gun run and they were
working in conjunction with the uh
the 101st airborne on their air mobile
units
and there was a like a river stream
and they were making a gun run so the
101st had gone down with the cobra they
had cobras in
scarface came in with a regular gunship
got hit
as it went down it flipped over to the
door
the crew members came out it crashed
upside down
they put out an emergency call on was
there
he responds to the call the gunships
went down
and they made a gun run on each side of
the down
upside down scarface he followed him
right in
and he picked up the two to the
crew members he picked up it was either
no i didn't pick up the i just spotted
them you spotted them first
because i i i threw along the stream to
see what uh
if i i cannot find any people
and i spot two of them standing on the
big ground like this
this table and i called them
let them know and then i keep so they
they came down
to pick them up and i kept crying down
the
stream to look at other people and i
couldn't find it anymore i come back
i came back to the the down hilly
upside down and i couldn't see anywhere
you couldn't see inside the cabin or a
carpet so i use my
right wheel to turn it back hmm
you flipped over the huey well under
enemy fire
and uh i checked the giants there was
nobody in there so i
tell them that i couldn't find anymore
then you have your crew chief hang out
the door
yeah and then he was able to say that he
saw people in the pilot and the co-pilot
because this day there's two those are
the two
uh only two scarface marines
aviators that are still listed as m.i.a
i think it was the pilot and
and the crew chief because the co-pilot
got out
and they were able to rescue those two
and uh
and the bubble of the front of the ue
where he put his
you know the strut put the wheel in and
lifted up the helicopter his crew chief
goes and hangs out
all while under enemy fire so
in august 2000 scarface
honored on at a banquet in san diego
to thank him for that heroic mission and
they helped get your
award for admission correct was that
part of that
no yet not yet but that was one mission
where he was just flying and they had to
call for help
he responded to help scarface because
scarface and 100 first had protected
king bees all the time and you got shot
up on that one too
it wasn't like we're just another day in
the park he's helping the marines trying
to find those
aviators and i'm not sure how many hits
he got but just the fact to go down the
stream
put the strut underneath the front nose
it had been knocked out and lifted up
to give them a status report
another day with the kingpiece amazing
yeah that you know uh the the reputation
you guys had must have been just
i mean that opening that i read from
this like yes it's just
epic you know to hear the the the relief
from watkins and here's who it is like
okay now we got a chance
yeah and it now that was always our
golden
our golden moment you're on the ground
you're in a firefight and they say
the king bees are coming it's like thank
god for the king bees
on that mission when you decide hey you
know what
i'm not gonna bring a co-pilot i'm not
gonna bring a crew chief
i'm just gonna bring me and the gunner
that's it
that seems like uh that seems like a
kind of crazy decision to make
no because we we when i know that the
situation was too bad and we have to go
go out as fast as we can so we can
bring them home as fast as you can
meaning it would have taken time to
round up the
co-pilot no if
one time when we was uh
they they were putting water in in the
nectar
and i saw i saw the the
the smoke came out from me again on the
other side of the hill
and i saw i am i run into my shop and
climb up and crank it up and when i said
taking off and it grew back up on it was
late
and he subscribed
so you didn't care if you had a co-pilot
or not no i did
well that's just like that mission later
in the book with the chapter 20 when
they
had the night bright light yeah where
the hatchet force had been in
they had severe casualties they had all
been exfiltrated out
the last helicopter went in was again a
uae
went in on strings to pick up the team
leader from the hatchet forest
they had a sergeant that stayed back and
the couple indigenous troops
and the chopper got shot down crashed
and then that night they asked to go in
this is october
69. and lynn black went in
and on took them out again with no crew
they took him out at night found the lz
and thought they thought they were going
to have to repel him but somehow he's
able to find
an area big enough to get the king being
it went down
lynn black got in picked up the picked
up the
team member had a broken back and the
other survivors
and then he came back again at night
picked up the team
i think this time they had full mountain
strings and then they pulled them out
was there anyone else that could that
could fly at night like you could
yes was it your eyesight was it just the
amount of hours that you had in the
helicopter
oh yeah you can see
you know that at that time the thing be
they we only have the uh
i see the c model that we got from the
army
have the adf vhf and
fm but the
d model we got from the uh marine
have protected uhf vsf
fm but
since the titan and the
vsf we don't use it often
we almost never use it and it's too
heavy and it was
installed in the tailbone and it makes
itself a heavy
table heavy so i remove a lot of them
extra radio is out yeah we don't use it
we only need the
uh um uhf and the uh
that's all and this leads me to a quick
sidebar
i don't know this is you or not but we
had in 68
the king bees had the marines wanted to
race the king bees
to fu buy so they had i mean just a race
a race race
they had their age 34. oh no no this is
just going from da nang
from the air base and the king bees go
we'll race you too
king bees versus what versus the marine
corps h-34s they still have some h34s oh
so it's just
it's king b versus king b yeah but it's
king b versus marine corps
got it with all the radios so the
marines had to go around
high van pass and go over to south china
sea king bees fly up and over
bing they get the flu by win 100
oh that was you enough but that was one
of our favorite kingby stories
the frenchman always told that one
man and then who's your maintenance
cruise
oh yeah was it was it vietnamese yes air
force
they were india they are in vietnamese
air force
and uh later on we
have the uh
let's see what what was that i said they
forget l-o-i-l-o-d
the uh this is a american company oh
american company yeah they their
their main job is only to
to replace the uh part
i said i supposed to change the tail and
the
tail rotor they bring the whole the
whole set
and put it on this is changing
but i don't trust them you know why
why because one time
after they uh changed the uh
the tail roses and
after i checked everything i started to
clean up the uh sharpen
paint of the engine and the choppers
started jumping up
up and down up and down and i just split
up the uh
needle and uh cut up the engine and the
the shuffle will stick like this and it
stuck the nose come up
and i go down and check look around
check check and check the tail
oh my god guys only only one more other
three braids and
remain he's supposed to have that
four braids
not there a tail ruler was m.i.a
that could ruin your day yeah we had a
um
uh in vietnam for the seals in vietnam
they
they had a similar relationship that the
sog guys had with the kimbees
with the with the sea wolves and
they had to kind of improvise
improvise and their maintenance they
were very proud of and
and very proud of their maintenance
crews because their maintenance crews
would keep those
aircraft running and they would do
whatever they had to do and
rob cheat and steal to they were
surrounded that's right
that's right and they were already you
know using birds that had
i forget they scrounged up the aircraft
themselves from somewhere they were kind
of leftover aircraft
and and so the it wasn't just the the
pilots
and the gunners and then on top of that
these incredibly hard-working you know
sailors in the navy that were making
those birds
able to fly on a moment's notice but
it's just
it's a very similar relationship for the
saw guys and the king bee pilots
it as it is for the seals and the and
the sea wolf guys
oh they're of legend absolutely yeah
outstanding yeah and and just the um
it's a similar you know the the attitude
you know what you said
khan or on earlier when i asked you you
know what
what are you thinking about when you
need to go back into a spot where two
king bees have already shot down i've
been shot
down and your response was i want to get
my friends out that's
it that's that's that's the esprit de
corps that is just
unmatched you know and and having that
relationship with
and just that that
warrior brotherhood is and then there's
a very human side like there's
a few times after we get pulled out
right at last light
and we go up to the king bee pass say
hey come on i'll buy you a drink
and then captain tim would say i'm going
home to my family or captain tuang
no thank you but i'm gonna go home on
family i'll be back tomorrow you buy me
drinks tomorrow
and they come back and had time to get
in the clubhouse have a drink before we
go on the next mission
that's just amazing so you had this
whole yeah that's crazy
that dichotomy yeah they're with their
they're flying home to their family
geez and they always came for us they
never
you know we never had them say no for us
any of our teams
yeah no that's that's definitely
something to think about because
americans
we are always fighting in someone else's
country right we don't go home
we go on deployment that's it you know
there's no family
were you married during this time or
were you did you have kids during this
time did you have your
your brother yeah i i i i married in
1969 and
i don't remember if i would
shut down before it or after
i don't remember excited except that
last time
and you must remember uh you know going
on a mission
getting your aircraft shot up and then
going home to your wife and saying hi
honey i'm home
yep
every time i the i was
shocked and uh but they didn't
i think most of them many times they
missed me
yeah one time i fell back from uh
mid to quantity
the weather was very bad and we
flew low low about 300 feet
along the hillside and
suddenly this this somebody
fired a long line of i can't crack it
right on my at my ear
and i i look like that i look up hill
and i saw a lot of nva
you know in the civil war
yeah the front lines the seat
the second line the knee and the turret
lines they
stand just like that and they were on
the hill
and they're shooting at me
and and i i
i told my cruise ship
your back should make you like and i saw
the uh
yes they know the drought they captured
the
whole being in front of the front line
of them i don't know if they hit
they hit any of them or not but because
i was the last one
in the fly at that time and so i just
keep trying to make the quality
and back to quality i
i got i found 49 holes
he's flying from caisson where we had
fub3 he would pick up teams and launch
for targets from kson
and of course when you flew into caisson
this is during the
the offensive so you know that was so he
flies from that hot zone flying to quang
tree which is quote
a secure base and in route there's three
lines of nva just practicing target
hit them 49 times
yeah 49 rounds
what happened um the last time you got
shot down
the last pass the last time because i
was in
in budap yeah north of
my midway and
i inserted the team
and came back when they came back
just like when you are
when you are in service for a long time
or in combat for a long time
you have some feeling i would say
six failing and i feel something wrong
on the ground
you're now in the very jungle so i from
1500 feet i go down
to check it
at about 500 feet they start to shoot at
me
and this is this when you're trying to
extract them or is this
during the insert on dropping off he's
coming back
from an okay so after you drop them off
you're halfway home
yeah and you decide you're gonna go look
on the ground yeah and you start getting
instinct yeah and
i i got mad and
i said a big zigzag fly and they skip
the line on fire
and uh i got mad i said that
this is my land and i take care of it or
why you care you're there to shoot at me
so i come back
and shoot and i got hit again
and the shopper caught fire
the round hit the fuel tank and then the
fuel ignites
and the fire comes from the fuel tank
into the cabin
he's at 500 feet trying to keep the
aircraft stable to land
while on fire
and i was on top of the frame the frame
is coming from the uh
came up from the cabin to the carpet
and i
if i use it i land right at the right or
right
under somewhere around there it is
it will be okay but uh i don't want it
to be get caught
so i keep fighting back to uh buddha
so so your plane's on so you're your
helicopter's on fire
i'm fine you could crack you could land
right but you don't want to get
caught no because that's going to be
horror
and i tried to get back to a buddha
and the frame could help the flame keep
keep burning and
one time it was so hard that
i let i left all of the control
the collective and cyclic i love it i
keep my my hand and my at my chest
when i saw the when i left the cyclic
then the shop started to knife down
and i i saw the
route coming up and uh
i said i just tell thing in my head that
it's on it's over but when it comes
close to the treetop
the the instinct of
uh survival pushed me to grab the cyclic
pulleyback and he said the chaplain was
diving down
and then suddenly when i pulled the
cycling back so
so hard and it come up
i thought that the main road that would
come off but he didn't
and i said i saw it and i labeled it
and so this helps dive in again
so it it's a little like it try like a
thin line in the sky
and finally i make a glass
landing in uh in the open area
so the the the in the handles were so
hot that you couldn't hold on to them no
but then
at the last minute survival instinct
yeah
you knew what you had to do in order to
get some kind of a landing so you just
grabbed those
and when i saw the algae
it was flying at the 80 80 nautical mile
and it was 90 not go by and
i moved the cycle to the right and
pushed the
right pillow on the way down and so the
the shuffle at the 90 north of my
make a 360 degree
so quickly that i started to carry the
tail boom came off
but they didn't and they started to
settle down
and now and i touched down very smooth
and but it still starts still running
so he hit the tree and on the wheel came
off
the blade came off and when he stopped
it
i am i grabbed the
seatbelt lock and i pulled it
but instead when i can pull it my finger
open and
for three times i use my left hand on my
left elbow
to hit the buckle and release the
lock and i grab the handle of the window
because when i make it is to run and
they had
the window rental move over
and close it so i grabbed the handle of
the window
pull it back but it happened i like the
on the seat belt
i grab it but the finger open but
couldn't hold the
handle because the skin was burning
so i used my shoulder to hit the window
and i broke the window out
i saw from knee down
they honor the material which came off
with burnout except the zippers
and the uh the pro is still burning so i
wrote down on the glass
wet grass and to put it out
and after it was off i couldn't stand up
my crew chip went by and grabbed me up
and
made me uh guide me to the rescue shop
the number three number three kingdom
so then you get on the number three king
bee they get you out of there
and you obviously you go straight to the
hospital they
they brought me back to the
middle of the hospital it was a
military hospital in saigon
and i stayed there for it
until 11
am to next morning
next morning the uh one king
one pilot with king bay pilot from uh
danae
freeman with with the
american advice brought me to turkey
hospital
and that where i stayed for eight months
and what was that process like those
next eight months
oh they uh amputated my uh hand
and uh make a sheet spin clamp on my leg
because of my life when i was in the
hospital and they
uh today the the doctor
not to smith he amputated my
hand i i i asked him
how about my leg he said oh he didn't
know
until after the after the operation
they amputate both your hands at the
same time yes
and then what was the what was the plan
from there
what happened after that after that i
go back and for a paper for eight months
nobody treat them on the mentionment
about four or five months
but after that i will make it forward
through the years for two days
for the doctor to try to check it
and after that after all the treatment
they
sent me back to uh the vietnamese
hospital
and at some point i know you had a
brother that was a ae1 pilot
right he's a a1 pilot yeah and what
happened with him
he was on the 95 mission
and it was missing it's all right we
know
95 businesses were across the fence also
right no no
he was missing about around about 30
kilometers
not of now
attending
and then what was it like when the when
the war started to kind of wind down
for you know america leaving and the
communists are going to take over
what was that what was that like for you
um
at the end of
april april
95 yeah one was a
king republic came to us to see me and
my he was my co-founder this is in april
of 1995
1975. oh 1975. okay yeah i got it
and uh he asked me
what we are going to do and i say i
really don't know what to do now
is everything mess up
did you i mean obviously
did you feel like the when the
communists took over
that you were just doomed because
clearly
you were a veteran that had fought for
south vietnam
it seems like you would you you must
have felt like you would be doomed if
they
completed the takeover of vietnam
no i don't think so no
the uh the thing is that we we were
desperate
because we lost the world as well
and
on the uh
let's see
april 30 1975
i was on board one of the ship i still
remember the uh
the name the sea challenger
and when i heard the uh it was off
uh of uh so you were on an american ship
i don't know which is the challenger
yeah sea challenger
and uh when i heard the uh
announcement of a surrender from general
ming
oh my my tears just kind of came out
and i want to do something over the wall
but uh when i look back and i see my
toolkit
and he stopped me he stole me from
jumping out
so then what happened i mean now you've
got your two kids yeah
you're you're in vietnam the south has
surrendered
what what what happened then
we go back to uh go back home
and then wait for what happened
and
in uh
surul yeah in july 6th i just was 75
i was in they put me in the
re-education camp in a re-education camp
yeah what was that experience like
jesus please
just talk about uh
propaganda yeah propaganda that's all
and the thing is that the people who
they want to they want us to go to class
every day
and we have to go to class every day
they keep talking but the guy
who tell to do that
is this level of knowledge
oh my god this is likely
maybe welcome class to already grade
three
so you're being re-educated by a third
third grader yeah by the third grade
and they keep and all of them talking
the same way
just like the machine it's just
indoctrination
yeah doctor nation yeah how long did and
how long were you at the re-education
camp before i was there from
zoolight i know from june to
august and then how did you get out of
the re-education camp
one time i was uh going out with my uh
the other prisoner to clean up the uh
the camp and i was pulling the
bubble wire with them and
one of the uh one of the guy
the nva told me that you people are
working and we have the inspection team
from saigon to come see
and when i i saw that i heard that
i i don't wanna i i don't want i don't
wanna
pull the i didn't ever pull the bubble
by anymore i just can't
go along with my friend and one of the
guy
one on one of the guy in the inspection
team
he came by my side and
asked my name and my
military uh id
and uh after that he said
okay working with your friend
and he left he kept walking away
and about 50 meters away
he pulled out the notebook
and stopped writing something i don't
know
but one week later they transferred me
from
longshare to swimmer
and from at the swim okay
i stayed there for another week and
one day they
called the uh they announced on the uh
on the radio that uh you people have a
name below
prepare to be uh to have your family to
pick
your people back home
so that was it then you got out of the
camp yeah
and so now it's still 1975 1975.
and then what happens then what do you
start doing um
then we start to live with my glasses
after 75 you know you know what
after that one day they can they go over
to the south
and their life was miserable
you know the people who uh
everything is a stem
food stamp everything stamped
and uh
one month maybe each of them each people
already
can buy maybe 100
100 grams of meat a hundred grams of
meat a month of a month maybe
sometimes they don't but it's say meat
but in fact they can do they even can
give you either the hide or the fat
or anything
and i still remember one time when the
uh
one one of the guy who worked in the uh
in the district you know he uh he ride a
bicycle to around the uh
the street near my my house near my
house i said that
the face girl people go to my face and
my
my my my son he was at 75
76 he was nine at
seven or nine i don't remember he just
grabbed the basket
and runs two to one so he can he can buy
the
uh the fresh one but if he came late
it will reach the selling place
there will be rotten fish only only
rotten fish
so you lived in that regime
for how many years how many years did
you have to live like this
uh
from 75 to i don't remember exactly when
you were 84
about 84. and you and you tried to
escape a few times
yeah i did the first time i tried to
escape my son
and we got caught how was your first
escape attempt what did you do
oh i asked my neighbor
he she uh she has some uh some
information from other people
and so we every time we have to pay
and uh
the first time we got caught and uh
at a dumb gun ways out to come myself
and we were in prison
so they put you and your son in prison
yeah you know the uh
the the prison in namco
is uh listen
there's a case in so maybe it would have
cased
no not about uh
1.5 the size of this room uh they made
it from
the uh so maybe 20 feet by 20 feet or
something
not even that not even that and uh
you know the uh the treat and in the uh
swam
in the swamp that they go in the swamp
yes yeah
they cut it and they make make it here
just like a case
just a cage this is just a case and uh
they called the top with a bubble y
how were you planning to escape what was
the plan were you gonna go by boat
were you going to walk the other thing
we can go is by boat
by boat yeah there's four cores like a
lot of canals water
much water yeah very few roads
and uh how long were you in this cage
for with your son
uh maybe a couple months and then they
transformed
research for us to do um
yeah and uh you know the case
you know in the um nam khan
there were a lot of mosquito
mosquito and every day we have only one
you know the uh tiger beer
in vietnam yeah the model but this is
week
and every day only one one
bottle of water for one day for the
whole
everything for months you're like that's
in a cage with barbed wire on top
and uh
mosquito at about five o'clock
five pm we have to sit in there with the
uh
mosquito net if not they
but this is a swarm of
just like me
and after a couple months
we will move to uh
of somewhere move to uh
was it was it another prison another
please
how long was it were you in total prison
for and what why'd they eventually let
you out
or how did you get out eventually my
family and all the others who
the people who who organized the
escape they
get in touch with the local
and every time they want
myself and my son we will release we
have to pay
about a six or seven six or seven hours
of
gold six or seven ounces of gold no no
no not out
let's see uh point six or point seven
house that will go
where would you find gold they like
float
he just got put his hand in my pocket
and found a ring a gold green
and he just take it and put it in his
pocket
and my uh piece of cigarette he take it
out
and smoke and put in his pocket too
that's when you got caught the second
time no he's supposed to oh the first
time
so you lost your gold ring you lost your
pack of smokes
and then you tried to escape a couple
more times yeah another two times
but after the first time i saw that my
uh
my son is getting bigger and i don't
want him to
to be a scientist to be called to a
service by the uh
with the nba i um
him go by himself so your son escaped by
himself
did he make it yeah he made it in 87.
that mean he at that time he was 16 16
17.
so you are facing either you get either
your son escapes or your son is going to
have to actually serve in the nva
who you had fought against for however
long six years
right and
after my son had uh
have escaped and i brought my uh
my my daughter to escape out another two
time i got cut too
oh my god and was a punishment as severe
the second two times
oh no the uh
second time we said it was okay but uh
we
after we we can get out of couple months
after we pay
about 0.6.7 hours of
gold where do you find gold oh
luckily that my my
my sister who passed away
the early this year he sent
money to help my my mom
where was your sister my sister in
french so she was in france yeah
so she was able to somehow send money
yeah to your mom
no he he he she didn't send money she
sent
medicine medicine and i sell it i told
her
got it you were drunk at that time
there's no
no medicine to get them and during that
time too your father was killed right
my father uh died in uh 63
63 63 i'm sorry yeah
today i i where is the uh air force the
day you joined the air force
yeah we killed you my father did that i
passed away that day
so how did you finally how did you
finally get out of vietnam and get to
america
oh
in 88
then i heard the uh ho program
i am not a i have not qualified for that
program
you say ho ho yeah humanitarian
organization
departure and
it helped the people who was in who was
in service or
who was in prison in the communication
for more than three years
can come by to come here and uh
how did you not qualify for that because
the total time i
uh i spent prison is only two and a half
years
oh so you needed to spend some more time
in
can you imagine that after all his
service good lord
and uh so i thought that maybe i would
i might be uh leaving vietnam forever
so i prepare for my
what i'm i plan to what i'm going to
do to live but
at that time the
he said with me the uh
air force association in san jose
they met called masuoka
he was the air force retirement
so this is an american air force retired
girl
and he was working with the san jose
south vietnamese air force association
yeah and
he the southern
vietnamese air force association asked
me to
help me ask him to help me and
he went to vietnam and saw me when i
uh he asked me to bring ontario paper
that i had
and i brought it to him and
when he saw the dfc and he said
when he saw the what the dfc no the fc
distinguished fight cruise
what's that american award oh the dsc
got it got it got it or the
the it was flying cars got right okay
yeah no i got it
i misunderstood okay so he saw that he
saw that
but he didn't say anything but later on
he said that he told me that
he didn't believe it because usually uh
the dfc is supposed to give to always be
award with the american holiday
so after he looked all kind of pay on my
paper and he said that
he will try 100 but he is not guaranteed
and he uh came back to uh state
and
he uh called one of the guy who worked
in the
akai national archives and
that guy was
it was working with him in the military
when he was going out today that guy was
the
second lit
they founded the dfc they found your dfc
yeah and they found all the records and
the
uh paperwork on that uh
dfc wow
and uh
they managed the national inquiry
the magazine the national enquirer
magazine yeah
they they they they found and they found
the
um before four guys i
i rescued okay and uh
one pilot came to see me and yeah this
is a zone liner
and his uh squad command
is morrison and they came
the national enquirer bought the
airplane ticket that was a government
over here to the tv wow
and so then they set up that program to
get you back here so what year did you
finally get back here
or what did you get to america well
let's see
i came here in 94 1994 yeah like the
native law
what family did you leave back in
vietnam uh
my mom when i left vietnam my mom still
there but i
i i told my nephew
the uh the son of my uh
my uh my missing my brother yeah to take
care of to come over
i live with her so i can go
and i came here in uh
i left with them on january 10
94 and i came i reached
travis here to uh on january 15
94. and then what happened
did you have any family here did you
know anybody no at first i lived
in the same house with the uh
the chief of the the south vietnamese
air force association here
okay yeah i leave it for
six months after that i moved out
and then did you get a job what did you
do no yeah at that time
my uh my my son and my brother my son
and my daughter work
to support me okay yeah and uh
when you made it out so you had your son
and your daughter with you when you made
it out
my my my son came here oh that's right
so he was already here that's right but
when i came here in
94 my daughter came with me got it yeah
so your so your son and your daughter
were here
or your son was already here your
daughter came with you
and now they're working and starting to
figure out life in america
yeah how big of a shock was that to you
oh
at least at that time i was i was sad
because
just stay home and do nothing and
waiting for the uh
or what is going to happen because at
that time the uh
they were trying to get the citizens
here for me
so i can get so they can keep me here
and it's a lot of a petition at that
time
a good reason was uh have had actually a
lot of petitions yes say that they
say that they're doing this yeah right
and in 1696
yeah i got a citizenship 1996 you got
your citizenship
here in america
then you went to the santa clara fire
department yeah i
before that i i don't know i after that
i
i go to school for the accounting class
and after one year i got the uh
a job in santa clara for the fire
department
for almost three years and then they ran
out of budget and
i would stay up and an employed for six
months
and get the nurses up in the irs oh you
worked for the irs yeah
okay well i suppose we'll have to figure
that out yeah
he's one of them he goes from a good guy
a hero to the irs
and how long were you at the irs for uh
from
2000 to 2013
13 years and that was it after that you
retired yeah
and what are you doing now sleep and
watch tv
no more prairie fire emergencies huh but
at first i i was it was really boring
i i tried to look for the apartheid job
but i couldn't i couldn't
find apartheid
so then you just had to you just pure
retirement now
yeah you looked for a part-time job that
wasn't anything
i don't care what i wanted was anything
it's just maybe it's about four hours
six hours a day
you're ready to work yeah ready to work
sick of watching tv
and you're up in in this area here in
the san jose area yes
since the day i came here okay because
we might be able to find a job for you
somebody probably looking for someone
gotcha yeah with the work on that yeah
yeah
uh tilt did i miss anything i mean well
let me rephrase that i know we missed i
know there's all kinds of stories
um is there anything else that you want
to bring up no i think those are the
major
stories uh just the documented ones
indeed
because that's that's one thing i mean
when you talk when we talk when we broke
down your 3 000
combat flight hours i mean we could
probably
you could talk for you know 3 000 hours
explaining what happened on all those
missions so i mean uh
just unbelievable that you were able to
get through all that
crazy all right my friend he uh
he told me that i they they couldn't
believe that i still
alive until today for sure
for sure for sure um
so till but anything else though no i
we've covered the major points there
and uh you know just like that one time
with the marines need help here he comes
he just
went there under fire and so many times
his king bees got shot up
i mean 40 50 rounds with holes
just amazing stories and the men
or there's so many of our assad guys are
alive today
thanks to the king bee pilots period and
of course the other aviators but
in our case we had that direct
relationship with them they were our
primary assets
they put us in they always came to pull
us out
the pat walkers thing you let off with
just a classic moment
just captured the essence of that on the
ground
intense fire fight and here comes the
king beat
not only do you come he settles into a
bomb creator so you can get on a
helicopter and go home
uh on anything else you want to add oh
i think this is that's enough
well i'll tell you what it's just been
an honor to talk to you
and and thank you so much for coming on
and
more important thank you for your
service and your sacrifice
it's it's um we won't forget it and you
took so many risks
you took so many risks and you paid such
a price in order to save your comrades
and your and your brothers and arms
and to be there for the for the guys on
the ground
and we appreciate that and we appreciate
the fact that you stood the line
to defend freedom in the world so thank
you and during the secret war
the king bees were another secret that
nobody knew about
and so i thank you for doing this to get
the
story about our heroic on and the other
king bee pilots
unfortunately many of whom we've lost
yeah we buried
captain tulang two months ago three
months ago
and uh our secret war had its secrets
and one of the gems
one of the great assets were our king
bees and we salute you every day and
they're brothers in arms so thank you
for doing that jocko it's it's an honor
we appreciate it thank you thank you
and with that tilt and on
have left the building
and once again we are left with an
example
of what human beings can do what human
beings can face what human beings can
overcome
pretty amazing yes sir pretty humbling
yeah yeah
feel like we can do more
yeah i mean that's pretty much the
general kind of overall
consensus as i feel like we can do more
yeah i feel like
we need to do more i feel like i need to
do more anyways i don't want to
like bring you over yeah like group me
into your community
my whole process of trying to do more
because i think sometimes i think you
feel like
maybe you're good with what you're doing
sure well yeah i don't know maybe maybe
not but yes i think so so
you know he mentioned and we all know
that he lost both his hands
and then later on joined the fire
department so well he was an accountant
at the fire department but yes
he's at the fire department with no
hands yeah and by the way i mean this is
he lost his hands both hands and and i
asked him about it he's like oh yeah
well then i went too
he was no like there was no
uh hesitation in carrying on with what
he was gonna do
he's just gonna whatever i guess he's
gonna get hooks and he's gonna carry on
that's what he's doing and then at the
end
which kind of gives you an insight to
like how he's thinking where he's like
yeah i'm like retired
and i kind of just you know made a joke
like i just sleep and watch tv
and he's like man i'm kind of looking
for a part-time job like i gotta go
do some stuff you know what i was
thinking about if somebody told you a
story
where they said listen here's what's
going on i was in a helicopter i was
flying the helicopter
and that the controls of the helicopter
were burning and they were on fire
but and i couldn't hold on to him so i
just let him go
and then right as we were about to crash
i just grabbed onto him and i steered
the plane
i steered the aircraft the helicopter
and i got it to land
and we lived but those those controls
were so hot
it was crazy okay so if you heard that
you would think one level of the word
hot right yeah and there's no way
that the level of hot that could be
explained to you
is so hot that you lose both of your
hands from voluntarily grabbing the
controls
yeah like that does and then as you're
trying to get your seatbelt off your
hands are just ripping apart
falling apart yeah
so yeah and that opening that opening
that i read from on the ground with the
book on the ground by john striker meyer
it's just it's crazy to think you know
oh guess what
there's gonna be too dangerous so i'm
not gonna take
a co-pilot or a crew chief all's i'm
gonna bring is a door gunner and me
that's it yeah that's what we're doing
that's that's another level yeah
by the way you're sitting on a base like
warm
whatever i don't know cool maybe you're
an ac you just had a
piece of chicken or something like life
is pretty good
right and not to mention these guys in
vietnam they're
they're like have to go home at night
like till what's saying
hey oh cool i'm gonna go home now
because i think when i was on deployment
i just put all that family stuff out of
my brain
yeah i wasn't thinking about my wife and
kids yeah i was in just the
deployment mode i think it would be
really hard
to go oh deployment mode well uh
singing ballet recital with the child
with the daughter
yeah you know how they say hey don't
bring your work home or what you know
what's that saying yeah right that's
another level right there it's another
level
check so yes we can do more so
yeah all right well keep yourself keep
us we're keeping ourselves
in the game we're all getting older
we're not getting younger put it that
way maybe some of us are getting older
okay so you're just going back in time
when you edit video there's a thing you
can do that freezes the frame
right so that's kind of what you you you
feel that you're doing freezing the
frame yeah
okay cool well when you're working out
anyway you need supplementation
that's undeniable i guess you could deny
it if you wanted to
nonetheless supplementation would be a
mistake i think you'd be a mistake yes
sir
so anyway jacques supplements called
choco fuel so these supplements
include but not limited to joint warfare
free joints super krill oil also for
your joints general health
some omega-3s in there these are
important it's what i'm saying
also discipline discipline go
three versions no three versions of this
discipline powder
do you drink powder every day in the
morning kind of yes
matter of fact yes so i was thinking
about this so in the morning i drink
coffee i'm a
am i a coffee drinker i don't know maybe
maybe not
i don't drink coffee every single
morning but that's like as far as
morning routines go coffee's not part of
your
routine i know that's definitely not
part of my routine but it's the
discipline because you get a workout
right so you take the discipline every
morning before the workout no
i take it before i work work oh yeah
after the workout
yeah when i wake up in the morning i
don't drink anything i just drink water
water boom
yeah that's a good one all right
interesting that isn't true i
i just now i'm going to when i'm going
to the
jujitsu on the way there i'm drinking
discipline free
scoops all day three scoops actually oh
yeah sometimes
actually four there you go
but nonetheless and then um yeah so
there is powder version
also capsule version cool that's when
you're on the go
and then the energy drink healthy energy
drink
version see this is a good one
so in as far as energy drinks
go like we say you can have an
energy drink but if you even say an
energy drink kind of brings along the
stigma
of the energy definitely discipline go
energy drink
rtd does not have that stigma because it
is factually healthy
truth it's true anyway sometimes you
look at me you want me to
give you backup no on your statement no
and i just got that look
but then you were made a complete talk
right so nothing else for me to add
yes sir no it's good for you a lot of
times i look at you because
like sometimes you'll have this look
like oh let me uh like you remember
something yeah like you wanna you know
and i just wanna give you that
opportunity oh thank you
thank you i always have a nice thank you
for the opportunity
sometimes sometimes you say some good
stuff
anyway and also milk these are in the
form of protein protein in the form of
dessert
six and one half dozen the other yes sir
either way we do know this we're getting
something that's tasty
and good for us good for us so you could
essentially just say it's good
it's good because that covers all bases
yes
good for you good tasting it depends on
what kind of good because there's a lot
of kinds of good
and for good uh various things you've
been doing a lot before
a lot of lawyer activity with me lately
about well it depends on what you mean
by
yeah because it's noticing yeah because
you can't just blanket statement a lot
of stuff
like okay so my daughter asked me what's
your favorite color
so i'm like all right well it kind of
depends like let's say black was my
favorite color
but at the same time like i don't
necessarily want
everything to be black some things i
want to be red like i don't want to eat
a black strawberry i'll tell you that
okay you see what i'm saying though
a lot of these questions okay like i
said you're doing a lot a lot of these
questions
demand a little favorite color camo next
question all right well you'd want to
eat a camel
orange yeah i'll tell you that if there
was such a thing
if you get an orange that was camo and
we just called it a camo
instead of an orange all right well i
just think of
like what if my wife's face was camo and
that again that wouldn't be too bad
either
camo all right well whatever all right
cool i'll simplify my answers how about
that cool
cool anyway appreciated by everybody all
these worlds all these things
jocko fuel available in various
locations including
or domain.com yes vitamin shop
absolutely and as far as discipline go
energy drink cans yes available straight
up
and by the way also on amazon
yes sir also speaking of origen
or gmail.com you can get there you can
get
wawa florida right now wawa whole east
coast
january there i said it it's looking
like january for the whole east coast
thanks to the floridians yes the florida
troopers out there getting after it
clearing shelves
moving us in the right direction that we
can hope for a january
full loadout wawa the people from
pennsylvania are fired up
have you have you noticed that on on
social media people from pennsylvania
people from jersey
people from virginia are like we need it
up here in this wawa
yes yeah i did see a pedestal
probe in there for sure um
yes good okay back to origin.com
american made stuff including geez rash
guards
jeans american denim and boots yeah and
you might think to yourself
oh oh american-made jeans right
okay i know what that's going to be
that's going to be a 350
pair of jeans that's what you you might
be thinking that potentially you're
thinking wrong
actually you're thinking wrong get
yourself a couple pair of origin
genes and listen they're not as cheap as
we want them to be right now
but as we grow as we scale
we should we will be able to get the
price down even more
but join the join the club
of supporting america
that's true also boots like i said
also chocolate store it's called jocko's
store
and speaking of clubs we have another
club it's not really a club
it's just subscript yeah the club i mean
really
anyway it's a subscription-based t-shirt
scenario
i like that way better than cleb
club i think club is something that you
do unless you're in a motorcycle
gang club yeah then that's one that's
like one
oh so it depends oh doesn't it well
that's just sort of a cool name
right but it depends on the word uh what
you mean by club
why are you being a lawyer because
you're over here you know
you see what i'm saying anyway yes club
subscription-based t-shirt
situation which you are wearing one
today is this the initial
launch mode it's the one of the other
ones i must say that one's dope
yeah and you know i don't throw that
phrase around very often though
in a while yeah but yes yes sir lots of
layers
and yeah you know these t-shirt ideas
you know they come
they go some sticks some don't stick but
this is like an opportunity for all of
us to sort of you know capitalize
on some of the cool t-shirt ideas that
just fly in
from time to time yeah any and just like
the ideas come and go the shirts will
come and go
every month you got one shot to get one
of these shirts and they're gone
anyway doctorstory.com that's where you
can jump on that if you want also on
drugstore.com you can get the
discipline equals freedom uh good all
these stuff all this stuff shirts
hats hoodies you know some cool stuff on
there so yeah if you want something
get something that makes sense to me um
you can subscribe to this podcast too if
you haven't done that wherever you
subscribe to podcast i also got some
other podcast
choco unraveling with darryl cooper
which used to be called the thread now
it's called jocko
unraveling also grounded podcast also
warrior kid podcast
we also have a youtube channel where
echo
gets to manifest his little video
fantasies right okay so you will always
say that and hey man good
but when you think about it youtube
channel
you're talking about enhanced videos
videos that we
at some point started calling enhanced
okay maybe i made that up but either way
there are not that many of them they're
all just like the video version of this
podcast and some excerpts
of this podcast so technically the
youtube channel
is that's more you than anything so you
know i'm just saying you put it on me a
lot so i'm just saying
it's kind of both of us i don't know
it's sort of the outlet for your
stuff though kind of yeah i guess that's
kind of true like i don't see your stuff
being
out you you haven't written any books
yet that's true
you don't you do you have a podcast i
guess you have this podcast
technically yeah i guess no that's true
because yes if i want to express myself
in any capacity creatively yeah where is
it going to land it's going to land on
youtube like me i'm over writing songs
i'm over playing guitar
art i'm painting i'm drawing i'm writing
books
i'm just all but video that's your realm
yeah that you do that
yeah you make a video or two every once
in a while which is good which is who i
did
oh yeah oh yeah check
all right nonetheless yes okay so i
understand now i understand what you're
saying and you're correct
and i am corrected and i understand that
fully and i accept that
also psychological warfare it's an album
you know you're talking about you make
music sometimes you're just making
albums
yeah there you go so this is one of them
anyway there's not a music one though
this is jocko helping you
with each track identify
and help you overcome any weakness that
might that you might encounter
so um that one is one of those things
that's helpful but it's 100
percent effective
check there you have it also we have a
visual form of that flipsidecanvas.com
dakota meyer making all kinds of cool
stuff to hang on your wall
got a bunch of books the books today i
read from on the ground
we also have across the fence sog
chronicles all those three by john
striker meyer
tilt and also whiskey tango fox drop by
lynn black these are
some of the song books that are just
awesome about faced by colonel david
hackworth
i wrote the forward to that it's
available now leadership strategy and
tactics field manual
the code the evaluation the protocols
discipline equals freedom field manual
way of the warrior kid 4 freedom field
manual is out right now
you can better order that asap if you
want it for
christmas mike and the dragon actually
anything you want for christmas order it
right now right now that's my
that's my encouragement to you because
otherwise it's not going to be there by
christmas
you got all these everyone's ordering
everything and
delivery people and delivery planes and
delivery trucks are short
they're gonna run out so your package is
gonna be sitting in a warehouse
somewhere
and your kids gonna be crying and why
are they crying two reasons number one
they don't
have warrior kid number two they don't
have warrior kid because if they did
they wouldn't be crying about it
yeah that's true they would they would
put their emotions in check
so you might want to check that out and
also extreme ownership and the dichotomy
of leadership
echelon front is my leadership
consultancy go to echelonfront.com
if you want help with your leadership ef
online where we are
training leadership online all the time
go to efonline.com if you want to ask me
a question or you want to
figure out some leadership problem that
you have come and ask us
muster 2020 i'll let you know about the
the dates for muster
2021 that's where we're heading
ef overwatch if you need people inside
your organization that understand the
principles we talk about here go to
eforewatch.com
we will supply you with military
personnel
who are ready for their civilian job to
go out and lead
and if you want to help service members
active duty and retired
families gold star families if you want
to help out
in a bunch of different ways and check
out mark lee's mom her name is mama lee
she's got a charity organization and if
you want to donate or do you want to get
involved go to america's
mightywarriors.org
and listen if you seek personal
internal agony it's what you want what
you want is to cause pain to yourself
and we can deliver
you can get more of my lackluster
allocations
or if you need more of i think this
one's good if you need more of echo's
inexplicable explanations
semi-explicable you can find us on the
interwebs
twitter instagram which just so echo
knows what i'm talking about when i say
instagram
i know you only referred to as
the gram and on facebook echoes that
aqua charles i am at jocko willock and
most important
john striker meyer is on instagram at j
striker meyer
and thanks once again to captain ahn
for taking the time to share his
experiences with us
and more importantly for risking his
life over and over and over again
for his brothers on the ground
and for freedom
and thanks to every one of you out there
in every branch of service army navy air
force marines coast guard
and to all of our allies that have stood
by us on the battlefield
to protect the sacred ideal of freedom
thank you and thanks to those you in
uniform on the home front
police and law enforcement firefighters
paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service
and all the first responders
thank you for keeping us safe here at
home and everyone else out there
think of captain on
think of taking care of others think of
recognizing the risk of his mission
going into an area where they had
already lost helicopters and deciding
at the moment of truth that he would
just go with one other man
so as to save as many lives as possible
a decision
which for him was perfectly logical and
as he said no big deal
when the call came he went
and we all should do the same
go
and until next time zecko and jocko
out